>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Catalina Gomez: Alvaro Enrigue
is a celebrated Mexican author.
He has written 10 fiction books,
several of which are now available
in English translations including
"Perpendicular Lives"
and "Hypothermia."
Enrigue received the
prestigious Joaquín Mortiz Prize
for his first novel, "La
muerte de un instalador,"
as well as the coveted
Herralde Prize
for his recent book,
"Muerte subita."
He has also written for The
New York Times, The Believer
and The London Review of Books,
and he also writes for El Universal
which is a Mexican newspaper.
His award-winning "Muerte
subita" is now available
in the English translation
and is titled "Sudden Death"
and is published by Riverhead Books.
And this is the book that
we're here to celebrate today.
The book is a daring adventure
story featuring 16th Century--
a 16th Century tennis match
between Italian artist Caravaggio
and the Spanish poet
Francisco de Quevedo.
Enrigue lives in New York City
where he alternates between teaching
at Princeton and Columbia
universities.
Alvaro, thank you again
for being here with us.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: Thank you for
inviting me and for reading the bio
of someone so successful.
It's so fantastic.
>> Catalina Gomez: So to start, can
you just tell us a little bit about
"Sudden Death," a little
synopsis perhaps?
>> Alvaro Enrigue: There is a
trolling, most of the reviewers
and the critics always begin
saying that it's a book
that I cannot define, you know.
I cannot-- the American review has
a very strict format, as you know,
and it always begin with a long part
in which they tell the book somehow.
And it's not a book
that-- I don't know.
I know what it is about, of
course, but it's not a book
that you can tell what it is about
but it's mainly, I would say,
like a mural, like a big screen
representation of a moment
in the 17th Century or the transit
between the 16th and 17th Century
in which modernity was
invented or it's a novel
about the invention of modernity.
And so, the main characters
of the book are--
or the more visible characters
of the book are, as you said,
this painter Michelangelo Merisi
who was the first painter in history
that used-- that considered
metro more important than work,
that makes out of him a modern
master and not a renaissance master,
and Francisco de Quevedo who
was this fascinating poet
from the golden century of Spain
that had a life as rich and scary
as Caravaggio's, you know, because
what is told in the novel is true.
Both of them were assassins, both
of them were fantastic artists.
Quevedo was for a period
a pirate, you know.
He was a diplomat.
He worked with the
Viceroy of the Two Sicilies
that is featured in the novel too.
And Caravaggio is just an
unbelievably modern, contemporary
and fascinating character.
He was an openly gay artist in the
17th Century who made a statement
over being gay and being successful
at the same time in a city
in which one good thing that
even sex could be forbidden,
you know, that was Rome.
So, it's a portrait of
this period but the main--
those are not the characters.
The true characters are
the objects in the novel.
>> Catalina Gomez: Yeah.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: That's why it's
so difficult to grasp a definition
of it, because what the novel tells
is really the story of a tennis ball
that was made with the hair of
Anne Boleyn, sounds theatric
but this is completely true.
The tennis balls in the 17th
Century were made with human hair,
usually hair of dead people
of course, and this is true.
That's completely historical.
And the other object is a
work of art made in Mexico
in the 17th Century, the
[inaudible] scapulary.
The-- I don't know if the American
culture knows what a scapulary is
but it's a little image of a
saint or a virgin or a god,
if you belong to a
different religion,
I suppose, that you carry with you.
And this image is not painted
as it would be in the case
of a European scapulary
but it's made
out with feathers,
with shiny feathers.
That was the way in which
the Aztec artists painted.
So we know it will tell this story
of how those two objects make a very
long trip to a center of the world
of that moment that
was the City of Rome,
and they are displayed
during the game.
>> Catalina Gomez: So
perhaps, just a little reading
of a little part of the book--
>> Alvaro Enrigue: Yes.
>> Catalina Gomez: -- before we
continue with some questions.
>>
>> Alvaro Enrigue: This
is very serious, I mean.
[ Laughter ]
I think that it will torture
the language of your ancestors
in the next minutes reading.
I can say in my defense
that in Spanish I have a
very weird accent, too.
And that I mispronounce
words in Spanish, too,
so it won't be as bad as you think.
It will be natural.
And then there is this thing
that my kids are American
or Mexican-American
and they really--
they don't have accents, no.
They have very cool accents.
The little one speaks with a Harlem
accent which is just beautiful.
So usually, I take them when I
do readings in New York and we go
by metro and I practice and
they have opinions they consider
as all kids that their
father is [inaudible].
So whenever I read one word
that is wrong, they correct me.
But being New York City, the people
in the metro intervenes, you know,
and they say, well, no, I don't
think that's the correct word.
You say that because you're
from Harlem, baby, [inaudible].
So this will be a mess.
Sorry about it.
The name of the chapter
is "Beheading."
Jean Rombaud had the worst of
all possible tasks on the morning
of May 19, 1536, severing with a
single blow the head of Anne Boleyn,
Marquess of Pembroke
and Queen of England,
a young woman so beautiful she
had turned the Strait of Dover
into a veritable Atlantic.
The notorious Thomas Cromwell,
chief minister to Henry VIII,
had brought Rombaud over from
France for this express purpose.
In a curt missive, Cromwell
asked that he bring his sword,
a piece of miraculously
fine craftsmanship,
forged of Toledo steel,
because he would be performing a
delicate execution.
Rombaud was neither
beloved nor indispensable.
Beautiful and immoral, he
drifted coldly in the tight circle
of very specialized workers who
thrived in the Renaissance courts
under the blind eye of ambassadors,
ministers, and secretaries.
His reserve, striking looks, and
lack of scruples made him a natural
for certain kinds of tasks known
to all and spoken by no one,
the dark operations that
have always been unavoidable
in the conduct of politics.
People in DC know about that.
He dressed with a surprising
good taste for someone
with the job of killer angel.
He wore expensive rings, breeches
lavishly trimmed with brocade,
and royal-blue velvet shirts
unsuited to a bastard,
which he was in every
sense of the word.
Cheap gemstones were
braided with gypsy panache
into his gold-streaked
chestnut hair, the gems filched
from mistresses conquered
with the various weapons
over which God had
granted him mastery.
There was no knowing whether he
was silent because he was clever
or because he was a fool.
His deep blue eyes, which turned
down a little at the corners,
never expressed compassion, but
they never expressed any kind
of animosity either.
Also, Rombaud was French.
For him, killing a queen of
England was less sin than duty.
Cromwell had called him to London
because he believed this last
quality made him particularly
hygienic choice for the job.
On the morning of May 19, 1536, Anne
Boleyn attended mass and confession.
Before she was turned over
to the constable of the Tower
so her body could be cleaved apart,
she asked that her ladies-in-waiting
alone be given the privilege
of cropping her heavy red
braids and shaving her head.
Most of the surviving
portraits, including the sole copy
of the only one reportedly painted
from life depict her as the owner
of crimped and, yes, of
crimped and significant locks.
What is it about nudity, in
theory the great equalizer,
that excites us?
In their naked states, only
monsters should turn us on,
and yet it's the very sameness of
our nakedness that we find arousing.
The ladies who accompanied Boleyn
in her trials had pulled
back the collar of her gown
to reveal her neck before
escorting her to the scaffold.
They had also removed her necklaces.
They didn't feel that
the removal of her veil
and tresses marred her
beauty in the least.
She was just as lovely with a
shorn head as she was with hair.
The bluish gleam of her neck
quivering in anticipation
for the blow triggered an
emotional response in Rombaud.
According to one witness,
the mercenary was kind enough
to make an effort to surprise
the lady lying there bare
from her shoulder blades
to the crown of her head.
With his sword raised up
high and ready to come
down upon the queen's
neck, he asked carelessly,
has anyone seen my sword?
The woman twitched her
shoulders, perhaps relieved
that some chance occurrence
might spare her.
She closed her eyes.
Vertebrae, cartilage, the spongy
tissue of trachea and pharynx,
the sound of their parting
was like the elegant pop
of a cork liberated
from a bottle of wine.
Jean Rombaud refused
the bag of silver coins
that Thomas Cromwell offered
him when the job was done.
Addressing the whole gathering, but
looking into the eyes of the man
who had schemed until
he unseated the queen,
he said that he had agreed
to do what he had done
to spare a lady the vile fate of
dying under an executioner's blade.
He made a sideway bow to
the ministers and clergymen
who had witnessed the beheading,
and he returned straight
to Dover at full gallop.
Earlier that morning, the lord
of high constable had packed the
categorical braids of the queen
of England in his saddlebags.
Rombaud was an avid tennis player,
and this seemed sufficient payment,
the hair of those executed on the
scaffold had special properties
that caused it to trade
at stratospheric prices
among ball makers in Paris.
A woman's hair was worth
more, red hair more still,
and a reigning queen's would
command an unimaginable price.
Anne Boleyn braids produced
a total of four tennis balls,
which were by far the most
luxurious sporting equipment
of the Renaissance.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
When the book was presented
in Spanish for the first time,
I have my editor in Spanish,
he's a legendary editor.
He's Jorge Herralde.
He's really a living legend
of edition in Spanish.
And he said in the press conference
that the balls made with the hair
of Anne Boleyn were real,
you know, that they existed
and that they were in a museum.
So I have to pretend for like three
months that those balls existed.
>> Catalina Gomez: And do they
look similar to the balls--
were they-- how do they look like?
Just like a jumble of hair?
I'm just curious.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: They look
like tennis, like baseballs.
>> Catalina Gomez: OK, OK.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: They
look like baseballs, yes.
>> Catalina Gomez: Well, thank
you for that reading, Alvaro.
>> Alvaro Enrigue:
There is-- I'm sorry.
>> Catalina Gomez: No, no, no.
Go ahead, go ahead.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: No.
A few weeks ago, I was invited
to London and I made a reading
in the racket club, in
the Queen's racket club
where they still play this
game, the archaic tennis.
And this novel begins with Quevedo
bouncing the ball, you know,
the tennis ball so he can make a--
>> Catalina Gomez: A serve.
>> Alvaro Enrigue:
A serve, you know.
>> Catalina Gomez: Yeah.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: And I arrived
there and I had the chance
to play this very old game.
So they gave me the ball and
I got the racket and drop it
and it stays in the floor.
It's like a baseball.
>> Catalina Gomez: Oh, yeah.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: So they
are very small and very hard,
you know, like little baseballs.
>> Catalina Gomez: Yeah, yeah.
Well, thank you for that, Alvaro.
And I'm just going to ask you some
questions about the book and then
about your work in general.
So in this book, you
juxtaposed historical elements
with the postmodern.
You also inserted tweets,
emails and other current mode
of communication in the novel.
Can you talk a little bit about
this element in your work?
>> Alvaro Enrigue: Yeah.
I suppose that it's maybe
just a generation, I think,
but I have a resistance,
a natural resistance
to linear storytelling, you know.
Linear storytelling feels
not boring to me but sounds
like petit bourgeois, you know.
It sounds to me like a 19th
Century novel in which the sequence
of events is clear and
the-- and more importantly,
the reader doesn't have
an intervention, you know.
I believe-- and I believe
it honestly and truly
that true art is reading
and not writing, you know,
that it's the reader who
produces the work of art.
The writer just sets some
Post-Its there and the art happens
in the head of the reader,
not in the head of the writer.
The writer is just a vehicle
so someone can make art
as they are reading or
as he or she is reading.
So in that sense, I'm interested in
novels that are like, I don't know,
Swiss cheeses, you know--
>> Catalina Gomez: Yeah.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: -- that are
full of holes so the reader can go
through it like what we are--
>> Catalina Gomez: Yeah.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: --
when we read, you know,
that is like reading
worms, you know.
We're inside the book.
And I think that the more open
the spaces inside the novel,
the more comfortable the
reader will feel inside--
>> Catalina Gomez: Yeah.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: -- and will
be able to set a particular order
in the book and a particular
set of ideas
that are not necessarily
mine, you know.
I don't approach to
writing as a dictator.
I approach to it as a social work.
That is what I think it is.
Reading and writing is
always social, you know.
There is this-- Do you remember
Ficano [assumed spelling]?
He used to say that we should
forget about the 19th Century
and he was absolutely right.
This idea of the lone
writer, he thinks he's--
it's always a he, it's never a she.
>> Catalina Gomez: Right.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: That he's in his
house with the beard and a cigarette
and he's super serious and alone and
then the reader that is in the house
of the reader alone and
everything is bullshit.
Reading is a social thing.
>> Catalina Gomez: Yeah.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: It's
[inaudible] but there are a lot
of people a book is intervening but
many, many people before it arrives
to the reader and the reader himself
is reading with a lot of people,
too, you know, the recommenders,
the reviewers, et cetera.
>> Catalina Gomez: Right.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: So,
my books are like that.
They are more open than closed.
>> Catalina Gomez: And do
you also think about sort
of how we are currently
reading in the generation
which is all these little bits
and pieces in the internet
and being able to see, to read about
historical moments in our computers
but then also like watching a
YouTube video and all this sort
of broken pieces of information?
I mean, because that's sort of
what it reminds me definitely.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: I don't know.
I don't know.
I've written all my books listening
to music in a computer, you know--
>> Catalina Gomez: Yeah.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: -- which
is not to listen to music,
you know, but I listen to music.
I listen to a piece, you know.
But when I'm working,
I took music in iTunes
or whatever program you
have and is always broken,
you know, everything is broken.
The whole discourses of the 19th
Century or of the late 20th Century,
maybe the 70s was still--
don't exist anymore.
That's by one hand
but by the other--
a novel is such a marvelously
demanding object in itself
that you cannot decide
what form it will have
to please certain kind
of reader, you know.
To tell a story is so
incredibly difficult,
so damn incredibly difficult
that the form that the novel asks
for the form, I mean in this case,
I said it was a novel that is set
in a tennis game is not a
novel about the tennis game.
I had when-- The first time in
my life I saw a tennis game was
when I went to a Queen's racket
club last year, you know.
It's not that novel about tennis.
But as the spine of the novel was a
tennis game, the novel had to have
that form so the chapters are very
short, very violent and very strong
because you should really test, as
you see, a tennis match, you know,
moving the head from one side to the
other because the ball is bouncing
and the novel has that structure.
>> Catalina Gomez: Yeah.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: In the
beginning, you are, as a reader,
you are standing behind
Quevedo's back.
As, yeah, as a reader, you're
just-- that's the point of view.
So you see Caravaggio at
the other side, you know,
the monster of baroque, you know,
the man who will invent
baroque art in the next.
And behind him, you can
perceive, you know, Rome,
the counterreformation,
France, you know, Spain.
It's eternal duel.
And when in the middle of the game,
they switch positions and you begin
to see the game from the
perspective of Caravaggio.
You see Quevedo and you see Spain
became him but more than anything,
you see the America behind, you
know, the great and main monster
of the 17th Century, you know,
that thing that had to be invented,
that empty space that-- which
the story had to be told
so it could exist in the
imaginary of the people.
So the novel happens
very fast, you know.
>> Catalina Gomez: Yeah.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: In
the book I'm writing now
that happens during the 19th
Century, the chapters are very long
because it should feel
like a train ride--
>> Catalina Gomez: Yeah.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: -- and not
like a tennis match, mm-hmm.
>> Catalina Gomez: What also
the tennis match symbolized,
like this back and forth of the
ball between Caravaggio and Quevedo,
is there more symbolism there?
>> Alvaro Enrigue: Between the,
well, Italy and Spain, you know.
>> Catalina Gomez: OK.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: It's still
a-- when you speak about soccer,
that's an important game always.
Italy-Spain is--
>> Catalina Gomez: Yeah.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: -- a game the
world stops to watch, you know.
But anyway, no, I was--
I wanted, for years,
I wanted to write a novel about--
or with Caravaggio, you know,
which Caravaggio was a--
I read in long, long ago--
long, long ago, I read in The
New York Review of Books a review
of a new biography of Caravaggio.
He was in Berlin.
And I read this, I had it
from the plane and I read
that he had been an assassin
and that-- while he was--
you surely had seen many
Caravaggio paintings
because he was a superstar.
But that when his paintings, there
is a beheading, there is a character
who is beheaded like
John the Baptist or all
of this biblical characters
that are beheaded, or Goliath,
the head that is presented always
in the painting is a self-portrait.
It's always the head of
Caravaggio, you know.
So I found that incredibly
fascinating.
And I began to think about
writing one day one novel
in which Caravaggio was
displayed, you know.
He's such a theatric
character, you know.
And at the same time, he had a
studio that was a place like this
that had a little hole
in the top of the studio
and it was the only source of light.
So he will paint with
only low lights.
There were no professional models
in his life and he was a low life.
So he would grab all these
people from the street
that were well-known in Rome.
When he painted, he used a
prostitute to paint the Virgin Mary.
His painting was rejected from
St. Peter because everybody knew
that woman, you know,
so it was scandal.
So he would grab all these people,
prostitutes, beggars, you know,
tattooists, people like the bottom
of the Roman society, dress them
and display them under the
ray of light and that way--
and then he would project
that in the canvas
and then copy it, you know.
So, he was a process artist.
And what is more fascinating I think
or what they could find more
fascinating is that the work
of art is not what is in the
canvas but what he did, you know.
It was the performance made
by the beggars what
produced the work of art.
The canvas itself was something
that you sold to a priest
for a ridiculous amount of money
because he was familiar, you know.
He became very famous.
He was like a rock star, you know.
So this character was fascinating.
>> Catalina Gomez: Yeah.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: I wanted
to write a novel about him
and I read a thousand biographies,
spent years going from museum
to museum to watch his paintings.
They are not many for there
are only 63, now 64 paintings
because every now and then
one is found, you know,
not knowing how to write about him.
And one day rereading,
that's interesting,
rereading the biography,
the bio that Peter Robb,
I think is his name, an Australian,
another critic, wrote about him,
I discover that he
was a tennis player.
That before he became a famous
painter, he used to play tennis
in the streets for money.
People would bet on him
as if he was a horse
or a Jai Alai player
in the streets of Rome.
And I found that-- when I saw that,
you know, the idea of the so little
of the tennis court and
the people betting on him
as if he was a little animal
and he was the great--
he was about to invent
modern art, you know.
I--
>> Catalina Gomez: Yeah.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: The novel
was set there you know.
>> Catalina Gomez: Yeah.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: There
weren't nothing else have
to read only, except writing.
>> Catalina Gomez: Yeah.
That's great.
OK. The next question, so
through exaggeration, humor and,
quite frankly, brilliance, you--
I think you're laughing at the
way history has been written
and you're kind of
laughing at history
with a capital H. Is this correct?
>> Alvaro Enrigue: Yeah.
>> Catalina Gomez: Yeah?
>> Alvaro Enrigue: Yeah, I think so.
I think that's a privilege
of a novelist, you know.
A novelist can work--
I work as a writer.
I work as, you know, with archives.
But I do a lot of research
and I work in--
with historic materials but
they are not historical novels
because they are not loyal
to history at all, you know,
and they are not remakes of history.
They are mainly meditations on why
missed history with a capital H
which are ridiculous
discourse that comes
from very specific places, you know.
It comes from the clusters
of the universe.
It is, you know, and is told in only
a very specific way and that's it.
So, my novels tend to
be a meditation on that.
I think that the privilege of the
novelists is that you can tell it.
And when you are telling you
can propose different theories
about things that may make more
scenes than how they are told
in the academic works of history.
I am not being critical
of historians.
I would not be a writer
without their work, you know.
I'm a reader of history.
>> Catalina Gomez: And how was
it to work with Natasha Wimmer,
your translator, in the
translation of this work?
>> Alvaro Enrigue: Natasha is
to translation what Diego Armando
Maradona to a soccer ball, you know.
No, she really is.
She is a crack, you know.
She is a monster.
She is--
>> Catalina Gomez: She translated
Bolaño, all of the Bolaño--
>> Alvaro Enrigue: She
translated some Bolaño.
>> Catalina Gomez: Some Bolaño.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: She
translated the big ones,
"The Savage Detectives" and "2666."
And she has done a lot of work
but it was when my agent told me,
you know, it will be Natasha
Wimmer, I was incredibly excited
because I know her work well.
I didn't know her personally
but I know her work well.
And I have-- Even in
my class in Princeton,
I have worked with students with the
original of "The Savage Detectives"
and the original that she
produces because she's so good
that it's like an original.
And so I was an admirer of
her work and it was great
to have the chance to
collaborate with her.
And I thought that it was a
privilege to be translated by her.
But as we were moving
in the translation,
I discovered that the true
privilege was to see her work,
to see a true artist of the
translation produce a book,
you know, because she
does first like a mess--
she does a very fast first
translation of the book
that is very messy and shapeless.
And then she works with
an unbelievable devotion
but unbelievable word by word until
she has the feeling that it sounds
like the original and I have
that feeling, too, you know.
>> Catalina Gomez: Yeah.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: At the end of
the process, because we read the--
it's a novel that is difficult
to relate because of the archives
and everything that discussed in.
We did the edition with the
American and the British editors
at the same time and
their copies, you know.
And editors in copies when they
are editing really hit the outdoors
in translation, you know.
It's like a war between
the translator
and the editors on the other side.
And when they would
ask for something,
I will go to Natasha's
original as if it was mine.
There was a moment in which
I wouldn't have noticed
if what I was reading were
my words or Natasha's words.
That's a [inaudible] translator.
>> Catalina Gomez: Wow.
Yeah, right.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: That's her.
>> Catalina Gomez: Yeah, right.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: She is amazing.
Anyway, I think that a
translation is always an original.
>> Catalina Gomez: Yeah.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: I don't share
the idea that translation--
this Frost idea which is fine, you
know, poetry is lost in translation.
It was a joke, you know.
He didn't mean it.
I don't know if it's lost--
>> Catalina Gomez: So
you don't think that--
you don't think anything
is lost in the translation?
>> Alvaro Enrigue: No.
I think that that translation
enriches the reading,
you know, of the things.
>> Catalina Gomez: Yeah.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: First that
translation is a second view
on that book which
means that, in general,
it will be better meditative
and it's--
when the translator begins
to work, the book is finished
so they know they are--
where they are going.
So, the chances to
improve the book are real.
And by other hand, it's
through translation
that we renew literary discourses.
>> Catalina Gomez: Right.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: If there
was not because of the effort
of passing one thing written
in one language to another,
the language will stay
always the same, you know.
It's through translation that a
language renews and learns new ways
of saying things, you know.
>> Catalina Gomez: Yeah.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: So, I'm
a believer in translation,
a thing that more popular position
lately in the US fortunately.
>> Catalina Gomez: Mm-hmm.
And this next question is more
about your work in general.
So, I feel like your
work talks a lot
about structures of power as well.
In your first novel, "La muerte
de un instalador," which I think
that book has mistranslated to
English but it would translate
to "The Death of an
Installation Artist."
>> Alvaro Enrigue: Yeah.
>> Catalina Gomez: Right.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: It would
translate to that, yeah.
>> Catalina Gomez:
And that books deals
with the power structures
within the art world.
And then "Perpendicular Lives" deals
with the power of the
Catholic Church.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: Yeah, and--
>> Catalina Gomez: Can
you talk a little-- yes.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: It's a novel
about parricide, that word exist
in English, parricidio,
parricide, yeah.
"Perpendicular Lives" is--
>> Catalina Gomez: Yeah.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: -- a
series of characters that--
a parricide that reincarnates
and reincarnates and reincarnates
and he's always trying to not kill
his father and ends up doing it.
Yes, I hate the authority figures.
It's very sinful.
I can deal with it.
I'm the son of a hippie [inaudible].
My father is older
than the hippies were.
But anyway, I grew up in a very
relaxed home environment but went
to Catholic school
from six years old
and then I never could
deal with authority.
>> Catalina Gomez: Yeah.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: I
still can't, you know.
I tried. [Inaudible]
towards me but I can't.
So yes, I have a beef with that.
It's like a personal thing.
And I have a beef, too, with the
figures of the machos, you know,
the quite great white machos
of history are always displayed
in a cruel way in my
novels, you know.
I think that one of the things
that we have done really wrong
in the western civilization is to
center all the efforts in the male--
in the masculine figures and I
think that that's a generation
where we have this
fantastic situation in which,
for the first time, maybe
since 600 or 400 Before Christ,
we are able to dismount that and
see history and seek what we do
from a different point of
view that is much more richer,
not only the point of view of the
being macho but the other one.
I think that the way to
deconstruct that is to write
about the great machos of the world
and to laugh about them as much
as you can, you know,
and as loud as you can.
>> Catalina Gomez: Yeah.
OK, this is more about
you, you as a person.
Had you always wanted
to be a writer?
>> Alvaro Enrigue: Yeah, I never
wanted to be anything else.
I had it very clear.
>> Catalina Gomez: But yesterday,
you told me something different.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: Yesterday,
I said something different.
But I wanted to, well, I wanted
to be a soccer player or--
>> Catalina Gomez: A
musician, you said a musician.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: No,
but I never studied music.
>> Catalina Gomez: Oh, OK.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: No, but no.
Yeah. No, if I could be whatever I
wanted to be I would be a musician.
I have this reverence,
reverence, reverence--
>> Catalina Gomez: Oh,
I see, the-- OK-- yeah.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: -- for
music, but I cannot play a drum.
I could not play a
bottle of water, you know.
>> Catalina Gomez: But you've been
writing for a very, very long time.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: Yeah.
I always wanted to be a writer.
I'm a melomaniac, you know, but
you don't make money with that,
listening to records and
going to [inaudible] and help
with the family's economy, so.
>> Catalina Gomez: Yeah.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: No, but I
always wanted to be a writer.
I grew up in a family
that considers the ability
of telling a story important.
It's a family of storytellers.
It's a big family, it's a
Mexican family, so it's really big
and the meals are really long, you
know, as it is in Mexico, you know.
A Sunday meal would begin at 3 p.m.
with the first tequila and will end
at 10 p.m. and all the
time, the people will be
in the table talking
and it's a big family.
So in order to survive
to that family,
you have to be a good storyteller.
>> Catalina Gomez: Yeah.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: You had to be
able to make people laugh, you know,
so your uncles and grandparents will
learn your name which is noticing.
There's a lot of children.
Not anymore.
Those families are in
extinction in Mexico.
>> Catalina Gomez: Right.
Yeah.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: Now, they are
these like American families,
you know, a bunch of
old people and one kid.
>> Catalina Gomez: Yeah.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: But when I
was a kid, it was different.
>> Catalina Gomez: Who have
been the artists and writers
that have influenced you the most?
>> Alvaro Enrigue:
I don't know about--
The question about
influence is always weird--
>> Catalina Gomez:
They're difficult?
>> Alvaro Enrigue: -- because I--
of course, you can speak about
writers you want to be as
and writers that you read
and you say wow, this is it.
But I think that every
good thing is an influence.
>> Catalina Gomez: Yeah.
I would say that I would
not be the writer that I am,
whatever kind of writer I am, if it
was not because of the folk songs
of Jose Alfredo Jimenez that I
would quote that as a big source
of poetic knowledge for me even
when he was not a great poet,
but he was the prince
of record and machos.
He was so ridiculous
in those things,
but he wrote fantastic songs.
The same thing I could
say about Agustin Lara,
you know, who wrote [inaudible]--
>> Catalina Gomez: Yeah, yeah.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: -- et cetera.
But at the same, of course,
that writers influenced you
and I wish it were like great
Greek writers but the truth is
that they tend to be
American writers.
I grew up in this-- in the
post-revolutionary Mexico
in the Mexico of, you know,
this thing that we have now
that who knows what it is,
but the genuine Partido
Revolucionario Institucional
which was ultranationalist, ultra
close, and kind of socialist.
So I grew up in this country
in which it was impossible
to get foreign books.
You have to read only
books in Spanish
and those books were
only Latin American.
In the 70s, the educational
programs changed and in the school,
you would only read
Latin American writers.
You grow up without knowing
that Dostoyevsky existed.
Maybe the Dostoyevsky
because you are Russian
and Russians were communist so maybe
you could read a Cuban translation
of Dostoyevsky's.
>> Catalina Gomez: Yeah.
>> Alvaro Enrigue:
But the rest of the--
we grew up without reading
Jane Austen, for example.
I didn't know that she
existed until I was,
I don't know, 17, 18 years old.
So, anyway, there was this moment in
which Mexico, that closeness began
to crack before the signing of
the NAFTA and foreign books begin
to arrive and that would be
Spanish and Argentinian translations
of literary works of England
and the United States
and that drove me crazy.
The discovery, for example,
of Don DeLillo for me was
like the source of
everything, you know.
Finally, I was finding a writer that
was not center in his own discourse,
as the boom writers were, the big
geeks of Latin American literature,
but a writer who was centered
in how the novel works,
novels that were not poetic
discourses over the reality
but incredibly well
crafted machineries.
In that sense authors like Ian
McEwan was incredibly important
for me.
That this book "Flaubert's Parrot"
by-- I'm forgetting the name.
What's the name of him?
>> Julian Barnes.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: By Julian Barnes.
You know, all of those books were--
" A History of the World
in 10 1/2 Chapters."
>> Catalina Gomez: Yeah.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: They
were very important.
In the Spanish side, I
discovered very young,
this incredible Spanish
author that now he's--
will be a [inaudible]
soon, Enrique Vila-Matas.
And he was influence, too, you know.
>> Catalina Gomez: Yeah.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: He was
such an eccentric writer,
a writer that only writes about
writing but he's very fond
and very respectful of everything.
So, those were more
or less the readings
that influenced me, if that exists.
>> Catalina Gomez: OK.
I think we have enough time to
open the room for questions.
So, if anyone has a question,
I think there's two microphones
in either side of the room.
>> You mentioned Caravaggio
and Quevedo
and Quevedo is a [inaudible].
You are at Princeton and probably
Firestone Library has the best
collection of Quevedo's
notebooks when he was
in school as once before.
You accessed those things at
Firestone Library in Princeton?
>> Alvaro Enrigue: Yes, I did.
Yes, I do, of course.
I wrote this book in the--
the second half of it, the--
I worked on it for two
years and in the first year,
I worked in the public library,
New York's Public Library.
I had the sort of privilege of
having the Cullman Fellowship
that is one year in which the New
York Public Library pays you an
incredibly good salary
just to be reading there.
The theory is that you would be
reading and writing but the truth is
that I spent the whole
year just reading.
And they have an incredible
art collection there.
And then the second year, I
was teaching at the program
with fellowship too at the--
program in Latin American Studies
of Princeton University and I would
work in Firestone all the time.
One of the reasons why I
always return to the US is
because of the libraries, you know.
The library culture in the
US is just fantastic and--
but I don't have to say that
in this event and in this town.
I wrote my dissertation
in the Library of Congress
and I will always be nostalgic about
those years in which I was so poor
and everything was so difficult,
but I could spend eight hours a
day inside the Library of Congress.
I'm going to cry.
It's happiness for me.
The New York Public
Library is-- there's not--
no mythical animal as
the Library of Congress.
No, there's nothing
like that in the world.
But the New York Public
Library is a good one, too,
and Firestone is amazing.
Between both of them, I think
have more documents than anything.
And then I worked in
other libraries, too.
I went to, in search
of certain documents,
I went to Austin because-- the
University of Texas in Austin
because they-- you work in
the Spanish reading room here.
>> Catalina Gomez: Yeah, but--
>> Alvaro Enrigue: The
Spanish reading room
in Austin has the best
collection of documents
about Mexico in the whole world.
There is not even in Mexico
a collection like that one.
And I saw things there
that are amazing.
The book tells one of
those subjects that--
I had one of those subjects that
was the copy of Thomas More "Utopia"
that was read by the first
archbishop of Mexico,
Juan de Zumarraga, the author
of the Virgin of Guadalupe,
the guy who invented the Virgin
of Guadalupe, and he was--
it was given to him through Vasco,
the founder of the great Latin
American utopias, the original one.
So you can see the first
Latin American like pioneer
of utopic thinking making notes on
the book of-- on "Utopia," you know.
It's just a privilege, you know,
to be able to touch that book.
Sorry, I take super
long in everything.
>> Hi, Alvaro.
I've enjoyed listening
to you talk very much.
Could you talk about the
writing process and how you go
about drafting and editing and
whether you have a schedule
or just sort of what
is your approach to--
when you've had the idea
to when you're ready
to hand it over for publication.
>> Alvaro Enrigue:
It's always a mystery.
I think that I had never--
I published right now maybe
seven books of fictions.
I'm not sure how many books,
something around seven, six,
eight, something like that.
I never-- the day in
which I finish the novel,
I thought in the morning I
will finish today, you know.
I never felt that I was
even close to finishing.
It's just that there is a moment
in which you cannot move forward
anymore and then that's it.
But the-- So I don't know.
But I work in the mornings.
I am a morning person so I
wake up incredibly early.
I wake up at 4:30 every day.
That's because I have
children, too, and like I have--
I teach a zillion classes,
[inaudible] writing.
I'm super as much so I
live in the most expensive
and demanding city in the universe.
So I need to teach classes whole
day and I'm always doing journalism.
I have many things to
do during the days.
So I work for sure from 4:30 to 7.
And two or three days of the
week I can keep work longer.
But I can never write a
word afternoon, you know.
After lunch, I'm done with writing
and I devote most of the time
to teaching, of course,
but to reading.
I spent a lot of time reading too.
Other than that, I don't
have any method or--
I write by hand in
notebooks and with pencils.
So I have this love for
pencils and sharpeners.
And so I-- all my novels,
the original originals,
are in notebooks.
>> You said earlier that, at
the book signing that your--
the English language translation of
your current book is a bit longer
and I wasn't sure if
you were joking or not.
Is that true?
>> Alvaro Enrigue: No, it is true.
>> Could you go talk about--
more about the translation?
>> Alvaro Enrigue: I'm being nailed
for the things I said
previously to this.
But next time, I will
be shut up [inaudible].
No, the-- I think that the book
is a living animal, you know,
and I think that the book is
not a work of art or something
that was dictated by this thing,
Holy Spirit, or any of that crap
that comes from the 19th Century.
I think that the book is a register
of someone's mind working during
that period of time and that time
was being the book, you know.
In that sense, as I speak
English well with an awful accent
but I write very well in English
or very competently, I could have,
in the two years of difference
between the launching of the book
in Spanish and the
publishing of the translation,
reality changes a little bit
so I was able to add a couple
of chapters, maybe I
think three chapters
to the book in English, you know.
And they are written in English
and there is one about the names,
for example, that doesn't
exist in the Spanish.
There is one about the sport.
There are very few.
And it is true too that as
people begin to read the novel,
people begin to discover that many
of the historical facts were not
that historical and there
was some backlash in Spanish
when people discover that
not everything was true.
So, the novel in English
is much more clear about--
you will always be lost,
that's the idea, you know,
that you'll never know
what is real and what comes
from mystery and whatnot.
But anyway, the original in English
is more pointed to the reader
that don't necessarily have
to believe what is
told there, you know.
So, the novel in English
has like the instructions
to read the novel that
says like that.
>> Catalina Gomez: One more, yeah.
OK.
>> Yeah, I was going to ask, I
know you said your interpretation
of the history and how your--
yeah, I almost share your lack
of just respect for authority
for authority's sake and
how you're not afraid
to challenge the university
because they're tagged
with as being in authority.
You're saying that your
interpretation may be just as valid
as their interpretation may have
been or maybe even more accurate.
And then you got into the
comedy in making, you know,
laughing at that concept of history,
capital H, and the, you know,
the macho guy and what do you--
can you speak on comedy's ability
to kind of depedestalize ?authority.
And once you laugh at them,
there's a respect lost.
So, could you speak on that?
>> Alvaro Enrigue: Could you
say just the question again?
>> Like comedy's ability,
like using laughter or like--
>> Catalina Gomez: Humor.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: Humor.
Oh, comedy's ability, comedy's--
>> Yeah, sort of using ridicule
to depedestalize authority.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: I think that
it were only a more effective tool
to defend against the
powerful ones, you know.
We as citizens live oppressed and
destroyed by the institutions,
by the paternal feels,
but all of these things
that are there just fucking with
your freedom and your ability
to say things and your
capacity to have fun
and to listening to music in peace.
So I think that the only we
have is laugh about them.
It's the only thing we can do.
Still, the other one is a
revolution but [inaudible].
I've done enough with--
I would never recommend.
[ Laughter ]
>> Thank you very much for bringing
your books to us and all that you do
and I know that you're often
here in DC for different events
and I always get to see you.
But this is the first
time I'm actually here
to see you talk about
one of your books.
I have a question about
"Muerte subita."
There's one point in which you
interject yourself and it's clear
that it's you thinking out loud
and it's projecting yourself
through the book but you say
maybe this novel is trying to--
maybe this novel is about
how to tell this novel.
Did you realize that when
you were writing the book
or were you intending to that be?
>> Alvaro Enrigue: No, it's always
that I have always thought
and he's not myself.
It's fiction.
It's all fiction.
When I was writing the novel,
I was thinking in a narrator
that it's a person with
different experience than me.
It's a novel about
beheadings, of course.
If you write a novel
about Caravaggio,
there will be beheadings
all over the place.
So, I was, in the novel,
I was thinking in the fear
of a Mexican poet whose one
of his kids was standing
in the wrong place the
wrong day when the--
and was brought by some fight
between drug dealing gangs
or something and he had
a brutal death, the kid.
So, I was thinking about the
father when I was writing the novel
and I was trying to stand
on his feet, you know,
to be able to write this novel
that I don't know if you noticed
but he's a person that is
tremendously disappointed
and depressed, the narrator.
I am not and I still believe
that there's a way to cure this
and I still believe
that I'm not depressed.
And when I'm depressed, I drink
a coffee and I'm happy again.
But believe me, the narrator
of the novel is that, you know,
that it's something that I believe.
I think that what novels are about,
that was your first question,
is about how they were
told, you know.
I think that since [inaudible],
all the books are the book
in these structures, you know, or
all the books I like are the books
that reteach you how to
read literature, you know,
and that's the wonder
of the novel, too.
Every novel is the first and
the last novel that was written.
Since that's the gift,
the enormous gift
that Cervantes gave us, you know.
So, a form that is so
free and so malleable,
that every novel will be the
ultimate novel, you know.
Every novel is always experimental
because it cannot be
equal to any other.
All of that is there, of course,
in the voice of the narrator.
But I have problems with
that because that paragraph
that is quoted always,
always, always,
begins in I don't know
what this book is about.
And imagine the very
resentful reviewers
of Amazon can do with that sentence.
[ Laughter ]
[ Inaudible Remark ]
>> I think you're on
this critic, though.
Thank you.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: Thank you.
>> Catalina Gomez:
Unfortunately, we ran out of time.
>> Oh no.
>> Catalina Gomez: Yeah.
>> Alvaro Enrigue:
[Inaudible], three seconds.
>> OK. I just want to say I'm
a new reader to your work.
I really enjoy the book especially
how it's set up with all the duality
in it, the old world versus new
world and Spanish versus Italian.
I'm really looking forward to
reading more of your work and I want
to know what is available for
me that has been translated
and what is kind of in the
translation process that's
still coming?
>> Alvaro Enrigue: Well, I spoke
about the translation process,
the only book that you
can get in English--
>> It's "Hypothermia."
It was the only one
I was able to find.
>> Alvaro Enrigue:
It's "Hypothermia."
That is a very fun book about-- and
this would touch, in two seconds,
the problem of translation.
"Hipotermia" in Spanish
is a novel and in English,
it's a book of short stories.
It's a mystery.
It's a total mystery.
I don't know how that happened
because I read English perfectly
and I work with my translators and
I work in this one and somehow,
"Hipotermia" in English
is a short stories novel
but you can read it too as a novel.
The original one is read as a novel.
It's just that the characters
changed but the time evolution
and the way in which their lives
keep going is always linear
as in the novel.
>> I'm officially requesting more.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: Thank you.
I will give you the
email of my publisher.
They would be very happy.
>> Catalina Gomez: Thank
you so much, Alvaro.
>> Alvaro Enrigue: Thank you.
No, thank you.
Thank you.
>> Catalina Gomez: And thank
you everyone for being here.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us as loc.gov.